oh well I was always in all of the form
I i did my first novel before i did my
first short story i I earnestly pray I
hope that it isn't novel fatigue because
i have actually I miss I miss the novel
I'm working on one now which I hope will
you know which will give me the
satisfactions that you know I have
always got from from the novel now it's
it can be you know can be harder to
write a good story than to to write a
novel in a way you've got the impulse to
to shorten to compress if you don't
watch it you know you can suppress
everything you can but you do get it you
do get an impulse to make it simple make
it make it short oh but i i'm i am
interested in in stories my stories are
different from my novels in that I think
I I don't forgive people as readily in
my characters I don't forgive my
characters in short stories to the
extent that I do in a novel I think I'm
pretty hard on them actually and if I
have a criticism of you know of some of
the some of the stories it's it's that
their that they're little meaner than I
oh I'm a little meaner to those some of
those characters than I would you know
then I got to be but I find it I do find
it fascinating to write to write stories
to make to make them short to deal with
subjects briefly
well one thing I did just in in a kind
of incidental way I had never used the
first person infection before I did that
I have a story in there that's in the
first person something I'd never done
before and so much I did that I tried it
from you know to consider a fiction from
that aspect uh I wrote more I wrote a
couple things more about art I mean the
visual arts that I had I think
previously least one or two of the
stories are very much about you know
about the visual arts and and what they
what they are made to carry for you know
for the writers purposes in the story in
you know in style nothing I don't think
you know by in being my terms very
experimental but I did a few things that
I'd never done before
I just didn't find it congenial I I
couldn't get the right relationship with
the with with the narrative I mean I
just found that conventional past you
know he went you know it was Tuesday and
he went etc just the distance the right
distance between me and my narrative and
the I it was tuesday and i went i just
was of the space wasn't right the the
distance the amount of space between
myself and the point of view just didn't
feel right and that's you know that's
what you go on oh that's what I go on
it doesn't make it any easier as far as
I can tell oh I don't I think maybe for
some people it mellows it but I think
one has to be very careful about melon
mowing is a suspect process you know I
don't think I don't think you know what
a writer or to mellow too much I think I
think you have to be in a hard-on on
yourself and you know not indulge you
know your own you know your own lovable
peculiarities I think you you know or
you or you'll take you know your fault
you'll violate your best stuff I mean
sentimentality is the is this is the
enemy which is not to say that sentiment
is I mean sentiments is the real stuff
it's sentimentality that's the enemy of
sentiment but I think you I think you
have to it I think it's easier to get to
bitter than it is to get too sentimental
actually I think it happens you know
it's just as bad I think to be you know
to be cheaply bitter I mean sort of you
know cynicism is easy and and and and
it's cheap ah so to be sentimental is
inexcusable but to be you know totally
and and automatically the perverse and
cynical is as bad as being sentimental
you